geneviève dufour et professeurs et ico
directrice du programme en droit
international politiques internationales
de l'université de sherbrooke bonsoir
faire sur cet accord donc aujourd'hui
etats-unis-chine de phase 1 comment on
qualifie cette entente qui n'en est pas
une de libre échange n'est ce pas c'est
loin d'être un accord de libre échange
d'un accord de libre-échange vise à
libéraliser les échanges en partance
compte que les étapes des styles de
femmes dans un accord de libre échange
c'est d'aller beaucoup plus loin que ce
que les accords de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce leur permettre donc
c'est de se donner des avantages des
privilèges réciproque entre eux et c'est
tout à fait légal lorsque ça respecte
certaines conditions l'accord qu'on a eu
aujourd'hui qui nous avait été annoncé
en décembre mais on a eu le texte
aujourd'hui ressemble pas du tout à un
accord de libre échange
y'a pas les principes fondamentaux du
libre échange
y'a pas d'élimination des droits de
douane on va pas plus loin dans la
libéralisation des échanges
ce qu'on voit c'est et ça c'est ma
lecture rapide de cet après midi mais ce
qu'on voit c'est un gagnant les
etats-unis qui sont arrivés à imposer
aux perdants dans la guerre commerciale
une sorte d'obligation de modifier leurs
façons de faire vous l'avez dit ça va
amener des ajustements structurels en
chine à certains niveaux et c'est ça que
les américains sont arrivés à faire
est-ce qu'on a la conviction que les
chinois vont procéder à ces changements
structurels on n'a pas la conviction
qu'ils vont le faire mais ça reste un
traité international s'était faite
aujourd'hui c'est un accord en forme
simplifiée qui exige simplement la
signature des deux chefs d'état chinois
et américains mais ça reste un traité
international
après ce une fois que c'est dit qu'il
faut aller voir l'avant dernier chapitre
qui prévoit leur rue le mécanisme de
règlement des différends ou le c'est
assez vague
c'est confus ce qui est prévu on prévoit
que lorsqu'un des deux pays respectent
pas ce qui est prévu par l'entente
l'autre pays peu après avoir négocié
après avoir discuté à certains niveaux
peut décider d'imposer des sanctions
économiques
et c'est le pays qui se voient imposer
des sanctions économiques et pas trop
content mais peut se retirer de l'accord
donc c'est fragile
c'est très fragile c'est très fragile
c'est vraiment une victoire politique
qu'elle donald trump vient d'avoir et
c'est probablement aussi comme il le dit
une phase 1
une sorte de trêve dans la guerre
commerciale
la guerre commerciale est pas terminée
mais c'est une trêve que ça vient
enfreindre par les avantages que les
états unis peuvent gagner ou que les
deux pays peuvent se donner en quelque
sorte les règles mondiales qu'on s'est
donné à l'intérieur de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
oui tout à fait a priori ça al'air
d'enfreindre les règles du commerce
international
ce que l'organisation mondiale du
commerce nous dit c est à vous avez le
droit de conclure des accords de libre
échange de vous donner des avantages
réciproques à condition vous respecter
certaines conditions de forme c'est à
dire à viser les autres membres
soumettre les accords pour révision et
des conditions de fond c'est à dire que
les accords de libre échange ne doivent
pas être sectorielle ce qui est le cas
ici on l'a vu l'accord d'aujourd'hui
sectoriel il ya certains secteurs qui
sont je dirais même pas libéralisé mais
qui font l'objet de l'entente
il faut aussi que l'ensemble ou en tout
cas la quasi totalité des droits de
douane des restrictions commerce soit
soulever ce qui n'est pas le cas du tout
ici on parle pas d'élimination des
droits de douane on parle pas
d'élimination des restrictions
quantitatives
donc ça aulas hier à première vue d'un
accord qui est illicite au regard du
droit de l'om c'est oui une fois qu'on a
dit ça encore une fois qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire alors que les américains ont
gelé l'organe de règlement des
différends de l'om c'est en décembre
dernier et de toute façon nous avons le
numéro 1 et le numéro 2 mondial qui
négocient cette entente
d'ailleurs quel est le pouvoir du canada
et surtout qu'elles sont des pertes du
canada est ce que des pertes pour le
canada que de voir la chine conclure une
entente davantage réciproque avec les
états unis
on vous l'avait dit en introduction
cette entente là prévoit une
augmentation des importations ou en
chine de produits américains d'au moins
2 100 milliards de dollars dans les deux
prochaines années
qu'est ce que cela a comme conséquence
baisser a comme conséquence que les si
les chinois achètent davantage de
produits américains et russes d'acheter
beaucoup moins de produits canadiens et
pourtant on sait que la chine est un
marché d'exportation pour nombre de nos
producteurs canadiens compense en
matière d'agriculture
il ya eu certaines complications depuis
un an à la suite de l'arrestation de la
dirigeante de huawei mais il en demeure
pas moins que la chine est un marché
d'exportation pour le canada et donc ça
c'est un autre des raisons pour
lesquelles on peut penser que l'accord
d'aujourd'hui est illégale au regard des
règles de l'om c'est parce que c'est un
accord qui vise ou qui a pour effet de
détourner le commerce international
alors on va un peu plus loin dans les
réformes structurelles on ouvre le
secteur financier d'ouverture sur le
secteur financier une meilleure
protection de la propriété
intellectuelle
mais les grandes subventions
gouvernementales de la façon de
fonctionner de l'économie chinoise s'est
pas là dedans
est ce que ce sera dans une éventuelle
phase 2b c'est ce qu'on imagine c'est
moi je dirais que en ce qui concerne les
grands sujets de récriminations des
américains à l'égard de la chine
c'est pas mal réglée par l'entente
d'aujourd'hui les transferts de données
libreville la propriété intellectuelle
les contrefaçons dans les marchandises
la limitation des services financiers et
du terrain mais ce qui manque ici c'est
vraiment le fait que la chine
subventionne à outrance son industrie et
ça ça fâche énormément les américains et
ce sera peut-être donc dans la prochaine
négociation
merci geneviève dufour bien merci
beaucoup